bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
donc j'ai reçu de Monsieur Mo et thaï
brotherson député de la troisième
circonscription de la Polynésie
française une lettre m'informant qu'il
se mettait de son mandat de député à
compter du vendredi 9 juin 2023 donc par
une communication du mardi 6 juin 2023
le ministre de l'Intérieur m'a informé
que Monsieur Moïta et brotherson était
remplacé jusqu'au renouvellement de
l'Assemblée nationale par Madame Meriana
red arbelo élu en même temps que lui à
cet effet
donc j'ai reçu le vendredi 9 juin 2023
19h50 une motion de censure déposée par
Monsieur Boris Vallot madame Mathilde
panot madame Cyrielle châtelain monsieur
André Chassaigne et 145 membres de
l'Assemblée en application de l'article
49 alinéa 2 de la Constitution la motion
de censure a été notifiée au
gouvernement et affiché l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion et le vote de
cette mentionne censure la parole est à
Madame Valérie Rabault pour une durée de
10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues l'émotion
de censure que je défends aujourd'hui au
nom des députés insoumis socialistes
écologistes et communiste membre de
l'inter-grenue et celle qui doit mettre
un terme à l'abaissement continu que
vous infligez à l'Assemblée nationale
depuis des semaines vous êtes la
première ministre qui détenait le record
d'utilisation de 49,3 au cours des 30
dernières années vous êtes l'unique
première ministre à avoir déclenché les
49,3 avant d'avoir permis un examen
complet des textes par l'Assemblée
nationale
vous êtes l'unique première ministre à
mettre en oeuvre une réforme des
retraites qui n'a jamais été votée par
l'Assemblée nationale enfin depuis une
semaine et de manière totalement inédite
votre gouvernement et vous-même avaient
tenté de jeter le discrédit sur
l'Assemblée nationale en matière de
recevabilité financière des propositions
de loi et amendement
ce discrédit ce discrédit c'est d'abord
la manière dont les groupes
parlementaires qui vous soutiennent et
vous-même avaient traité le président de
la commission des finances Éric Coquerel
vous avez parfaitement le droit de ne
pas être d'accord avec ses convictions
politiques mais vous n'avez pas le droit
de le dénigrer dans son rôle
institutionnel
[Applaudissements]
dit
es sur la recevabilité des propositions
de loi notamment celle à branchant le
recul de l'âge effectif de départ de
retraite à 64 ans le président Éric
Coquerel a rendu une décision en tout
point conforme à celle de ses
prédécesseurs dans des circonstances
équivalentes il vous suffit pour cela de
consulter les archives de l'Assemblée
nationale ce que j'ai fait c'est cet
usage constant qui a permis par exemple
en 2019 que la proposition de loi rendue
recevable sous la présidence des rives
vertes la proposition loi qui visait à
des conjuguer l'allocations adultes
handicapée puisse être examinée et cette
proposition de loi crée des facto une
charge
parce que la décision qu'il a rendu ne
vous convenait pas vous avez dénigré le
président de la commission des finances
Éric Coquerel en prétendant qu'il
s'agissait d'une décision politique
votre ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement et aller jusqu'à dire je le
cite le président de la commission des
finances sa franchit du droit et de sa
fonction pour des raisons politiques
madame la Première ministre comment un
membre de votre gouvernement peut-il se
permettre de porter un jugement sur un
président de commission de l'Assemblée
nationale dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions
c'est une ingérence dangereuse et madame
la Première ministre permettez-moi de
vous rappeler que sous la Cinquième
République c'est vous qui êtes
responsable devant l'Assemblée nationale
c'est vous qui devez rendre des comptes
au Parlement et pas le contraire
jetez le discrédit sur l'Assemblée
nationale c'est aussi avoir empêché le
débat sur la proposition de loi
d'abrogation de votre réforme des
retraites il n'est de secret pour
personne que le gouvernement a fait
pression sur la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale pour que ce débat
n'est pas lieu cette décision est un
très grave précédent pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la Cinquième
République des amendements reprenant une
disposition
par deux fois deux fois déclaré
recevable par l'Assemblée nationale une
première fois par son bureau le 25 avril
une seconde fois par le président de la
commission des finances le 30 mai n'ont
pu être mis en discussion dans
l'hémicycle à nos collègues qui estiment
qu'on ne pouvait faire autrement je leur
réponds que la doctrine est très claire
et la même été écrite par Eric woert le
23 février 2022 lorsqu'il était
président de la commission des finances
et je vais vous la lire cette doctrine
la référence au droit proposé introduit
une souplesse permettant de ne pas
paralyser totalement les initiatives
parlementaires le droit à proposer c'est
la proposition de loi c'est cette
doctrine qui s'applique depuis 1958 mes
chers collègues sans aucune exception
vous pouvez faire le pointage des
comptes rendus publiés au Journal
officiel vous ne trouverez absolument
aucune et exception toujours pour nos
collègues qui doutent de cette pratique
pourtant constante depuis 1958 je
prendrai un exemple très récent avec la
proposition de loi 659 qui visait
assurer un repas à un euro pour tous les
étudiants elle a été examinée dans
tronic cycle le 9 février dernier cette
proposition de loi est arrivée dans
l'hémicycle avec un article premier
modifié qui restreignait le bénéfice
d'un repas 1 euro aux seules étudiants
en situation de précarité très
logiquement l'auteur de la proposition a
déposé un amendement pour revenir à la
proposition initiale c'est-à-dire un
repas à un euro pour tous les étudiants
conformément à l'usage constant depuis
1958 à l'Assemblée nationale cet
amendement a été jugé recevable
financièrement il a donc pu être discuté
dans l'hémicycle et en plus il a été
voté
j'observe que cette lecture de l'article
40 n'a alors dérangé aucun des députés
parlementaires qui soutiennent le
gouverneur donc un des groupes
gouvernement puissent qu'aucun député
aucun parmi vous mes chers collègues ne
s'est saisi de l'article 89 à Lignac 4
qui vous permet à tout instant dans
l'hémicycle de contester une
recevabilité financière dans ce même
hémics vous ne l'avez pas fait cet
exemple n'est qu'un n'en n'est qu'un
parmi tant d'autres qui montrent que la
décision d'irre sa vie habilité qui a
été prise la semaine dernière et
contraire à tout à tous les usages de
notre assemblée en procédant ainsi vous
avez ouvert une voie dangereuse celle de
l'arbitraire celle qui abîme l'État de
droit que notre pays a courausement
construit au fil des ans depuis la
Révolution française oui madame la
Première ministre il s'agit bien
d'arbitraire jusqu'à ce jeudi 8 juin
tous les députés
quel que soit leur appartenance
politique était traitée à égalité et se
conformément à un usage constant depuis
1958 depuis ce 8 juin c'est un saut dans
l'inconnu c'est le règne de la
recevabilité partisane sans voix de
recours désormais aucun député de
l'Assemblée nationale ne pourra prédire
le sort qui sera réservé aux amendements
de rétablissement d'articles de ses
propres propositions de loi madame la
Première ministre en faisant pression
sur la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez bafoué deux articles
de la Constitution l'article 48 alinéa 5
qui garantit l'initiative des groupes
d'opposition l'article 51 alinéa 1 qui
confie au seul député et à eux seuls la
responsabilité je cite de déterminer les
droits des groupes parlementaires
constitués en son sein
mes chers collègues
ce qui se joue aujourd'hui
avec cette notion de censure c'est la
possibilité de mettre un terme au
discrédit que le gouvernement jette sur
l'Assemblée nationale
et il me semble
et il me semble que nous devrions toutes
et tous nous retrouver pour dénoncer ce
discrédit et surtout y mettre un terme
ce n'est pas une question de choix
politique c'est une question de
responsabilité que chacune et chacun
d'entre nous avons vis-à-vis des
Françaises et des Français que nous
représentons c'est une question de
crédibilité pour exercer notre mandat
c'est une question de fidélité
l'héritage de la Révolution française
dont nous sommes tous les dépositaires
car qui d'entre nous peut sérieusement
se résoudre à expliquer à ses électeurs
électrices qu'il ou elle n'a jamais pu
se prononcer par un vote sur la réforme
des retraites qui d'entre nous peut
accepter la duplicité gouvernementale
qui consiste d'un côté à déclarer et je
vous cite madame la Première ministre
comme il se doit la démocratie
parlementaire aura le dernier mot et de
l'autre entraver le vote une proposition
de loi qui nous aurait permis de donner
directement un avis sur la réforme des
retraites qui d'entre nous peut se
résoudre à lire recevabilité ou à la
recevabilité partisane qui va désormais
sceller le sort de chacune de nos
propositions de loi qui d'entre vous
peut accepter les critiques incessantes
du gouvernement sur la manière dont se
déroule nos débats ces critiques ne sont
sans doute pas nouvelles et en sont en
Clémenceau les avait déjà balayé et je
le cite gloire au pays où l'on parle
honte au pays où l'on se tait ces
discussions
ces discussions on leur inconvénient le
silence en a bien davantage
mes chers collègues
censurer le gouvernement est un acte
grave et je le mesure pleinement
mais laissez perdurer
mais laissez perdurer le discrédit sur
notre assemblée par le gouvernement
marquerait un renoncement de notre part
plus grave encore c'est pour cela que
j'invite chacune et chacun d'entre vous
a voté cette motion de censure je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
alors que pour la 17e fois en moins d'un
an une motion de censure et déposée
contre mon gouvernement
je voulais commencer par un mot qui
surprendra peut-être
merci
merci madame la Présidente rabot de
montrer une nouvelle fois par cette
motion de censure que nous sommes bel et
bien dans une démocratie parlementaire
où le gouvernement est responsable
devant le Parlement qui peut à tout
moment tenter de le renverser
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente panneau
monsieur le Président Vallot monsieur le
Président de châtelain monsieur le
Président Chassaigne de faire une fois
de plus la démonstration que quel que
soit les événements quel que soit les
textes quel que soit les débats le mot
de la fin revient toujours à l'Assemblée
nationale
merci mesdames et messieurs les députés
de la nupesse
signataires de cette 17e motion de
censure de prouver une fois encore que
notre Constitution trouve grâce à vos
yeux et que vous ne resignez pas à faire
usage de son article 49 alinéa 2
merci enfin merci enfin d'avoir permis
aux Français déjà à 16 reprises de
constater que vous n'avez pas de
majorité et qu'il n'y a pas de majorité
alternative au Parlement
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
pourtant mesdames et messieurs les
députés de la nupasse dans ce moment de
gratitude
j'éprouve aussi une forme de perplexité
un sentiment sans doute partagé par tous
les observateurs de notre vie politique
et de nos débats avec vous nous vivons
en effet des temps d'incohérence de
contradiction j'en ai même bien peur des
temps de démagogie
[Applaudissements]
détendent d'incohérence ou ceux qui ont
perdu deux présidentielles de
législatives et ne dispose d'aucune
majorité sur ces bancs prétendent d'être
les seuls légitimes pour parler au nom
du peuple
ou ceux qui appellent à juste titre à
s'opposer au rassemblement national sont
les mêmes qui veillent à rendre les
textes de leurs motion de censure
acceptables pour l'extrême droite et
compte sur ses voies pour tenter de
renverser l'exécutif
des temps de contradiction ou les mêmes
qui tweetent pour empêcher à tout prix
un vote crée ensuite au déni de
démocratie
ou ceux qui se plaignent aujourd'hui de
l'absence d'un débat sur les retraites
ont tout fait pour l'empêcher en
utilisant tous les outils d'obstruction
à leur disposition
[Musique]
ou ceux qui crient à la mise en péril de
la démocratie parlementaire adopte les
méthodes de l'anti parlementarisme à
cause à force d'injures et de hurlement
ou certains se livrent à une parodie du
Serment du Jeu de paume et distingue la
bonne République la leur de la mauvaise
celle des autres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des temps de démagogie où les mêmes qui
exigent le respect de nos institutions
et de nos règles négligent les décisions
du Conseil constitutionnel et détourne
le contrôle de recevabilité à des fins
purement partisanes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés s'en
sort pourtant il n'y a pas les bons
articles de la Constitution quand vous
les invoquez et les mauvais articles de
la Constitution quand nous les invoquons
la Constitution n'est pas un géométrie
variable on ne prend pas les articles
qui nous plaisent avant de rejeter ce
qui ne nous arrange pas la Constitution
est un bloc et quand on respecte la
République on accepte en entier du début
à la fin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette constitution notre Constitution
permettez-moi de vous en rappeler
l'histoire
elle est née dans une période de
troubles graves pour faire face aux
défis de la stabilité économique et de
la décolonisation alors que la
République même était menacée elle a été
bâtie par le général de Gaulle et Michel
Debré approuvé par le peuple et conçu
pour permettre à notre pays d'avancer y
compris dans les moments les plus rudes
surtout dans les moments les plus rudes
la Cinquième République
c'est cette construction
institutionnelle qui donne toujours le
dernier mot au Parlement mais permet au
gouvernement d'avancer sans être
empêchés par les manœuvres ou des
majorités de circonstances
mesdames et messieurs les députés
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez s'il vous plaît
vous taire et écouter la première minute
vous ne l'interrompre vous ne cessez de
l'interrompre monsieur Boyard monsieur
Boyard je vous demande de vous taire
monsieur Boyard monsieur Boyard je vous
rappelle alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
je prononce à votre rencontre un appel à
l'autre avec inscription au
procès-verbal
je vous prie de vous taire et de
respecter cette assemblée la première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les députés
mesdames et messieurs les députés bien
sûr les comparaisons doivent se manier
avec prudence et je ne m'y risquerais
pas mais chacun mesure que nous
traversons l'une de ces périodes où les
défis sont multiples les bascules
nombreuses et les changements se
précipitent chacun de nous élu de la
Nation mesurons au quotidien avec nos
concitoyens les transformations
profondes et les enjeux devant nous
souvent j'entends certains dire que les
Français nous regardent je le crois
aussi et je sais qu'il voit ceux qui
tendent la main et ceux qui refusent
systématiquement par principe de la
saisir certains ici semblent convaincus
que le courage politique c'est une
opposition vocale caricaturale totale
moi je ne confonds pas le courage et les
décibels le vrai courage politique c'est
de sortir du confort de la posture de la
course aux petites phrases de construire
des majorités même avec ceux qui ne
pensent pas exactement comme nous
les défis qui nous attendent sont d'une
ampleur immense nous devons trouver la
force collective pour les relevés depuis
un an nous avons commencé les majorités
se nous les textes sont votés nous avons
trouvé des accords et des solutions sur
des sujets majeurs comme la sécurité de
nos concitoyens ou la transition
énergétique
d'autres chantiers nous attendent et
nous continuerons à construire des
majorités car sur chaque défi nous
devons débattre nous pouvons nous
opposer même fermement mais nous n'avons
ni le temps ni le droit de tergiverser
ni le temps ni le droit de bloquer les
solutions nécessaires pour les Français
je pense à la transition écologique
impérative face à l'ampleur du
dérèglement climatique et à
l'effondrement de notre biodiversité
nous avons commencé à agir nous devons
continuer accélérer partout en France
avec les élus locaux et repenser nos
manières de produire de consommer de
vivre je pense à nos services publics au
cœur des attentes de nos concitoyens
incarnation de la République dans nos
territoires nous devons garantir l'accès
de tous à une santé de qualité
désengorger nos services d'urgence et
continuer à nous attaquer au désert
médicaux nous devons répondre aux enjeux
de l'éducation de nos jeunes assurer la
maîtrise des savoirs fondamentaux
veillez au remplacement des enseignants
revaloriser leur carrière et réformer le
lycée professionnel
je pense à notre dette qui ne doit pas
peser excessivement sur les générations
futures nous ne pouvons pas renoncer à
conduire les réformes nécessaires et
privés notre jeunesse de la protection
du modèle social français
je pense à notre ordre républicain et à
la sécurité de nos concitoyens et
permettez-moi à cet instant d'avoir à
nouveau une pensée pour les jeunes
enfants et les adultes blessés jeudi
dernier à Annecy de dire ma solidarité
et mon soutien à leur famille et à leurs
proches et de saluer les forces de
l'ordre les secours les soignants les
citoyens dont l'action a permis de
sauver les victimes plus que jamais nous
devons protéger nos compatriotes contre
toutes les formes de violence et de
délinquance nous devons lutter contre
l'impunité et assurer l'efficacité de
notre justice nous devons garantir
l'application de nos lois et le respect
de nos frontières
enfin mesdames et messieurs les députés
nous devons agir pour le travail ces
derniers mois nous en avons beaucoup
parlé le débat social et politique a été
utile il nous a permis de bâtir un
meilleur projet pour nos retraites pour
ma part je n'ai aucun doute le travail
n'appartient pas au passé il est plus
que jamais essentiel pour réussir les
transitions écologiques ou numériques
pour conquérir notre souveraineté
notamment industrielle et créer la
richesse nécessaire pour préserver notre
modèle social refusez le travail c'est
tourner le dos à des décennies de combat
politique et syndicales non pas contre
le travail mais pour les droits et le
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs
[Applaudissements]
cela ne veut pas dire que nos minimisons
les changements dans le rapport de notre
société au travail mais je crois que le
travail a de l'avenir car il reste la
meilleure manière de conquérir son
autonomie son indépendance de gagner
dignité et émancipation c'est pour cela
que nous avons mené la réforme des
retraites c'est pour cela que nous
voulons donner aux bénéficiaires du RSA
les moyens pour accéder à un emploi
vivre de leur travail et sortir vraiment
de la précarité c'est pour cela que nous
continuerons à offrir des progrès
sociaux pour garantir l'égalité des
chances et lever les freins à l'emploi
comme l'ouverture de 200000 places
d'accueil supplémentaires pour les
jeunes enfants ce sont des chantiers
longtemps repoussés que nous prenons à
bras le corps et c'est avec le courage
de faire et la volonté d'agir que nous
atteindrons le plein emploi
mesdames et messieurs les députés voilà
les combats qui m'animent voilà les
combats que mène mon gouvernement voilà
surtout les réponses attendues par nos
concitoyens nous avançons avec
transparence cohérence tous les
chantiers que j'avais annoncé dans ma
déclaration de politique générale ont
été ouverts tous sans exception toutes
les initiatives que j'ai présentées il y
a deux mois pour accélérer et offrir des
progrès tangibles aux Françaises sont
lancés sous le regard de nos concitoyens
et comme toujours sous votre contrôle
démocratique nous sommes au travail
alors dans cette période de défi où les
enjeux et les attentes sont immenses je
le demande aux partisans de la censure
permanente voulez-vous continuer les
indignations factices les stratagèmes
politiciens et les références sélectives
aux articles de notre Constitution ou
pouvons-nous ensemble débattre de bonnes
foi et agir en responsabilité
dans quelques instants une nouvelle fois
vous voterez dans quelques instants une
17e fois l'Assemblée nationale aura
entre ses mains l'avenir du gouvernement
c'est le principe même de la démocratie
parlementaire et aujourd'hui comme
chaque jour elle vivra pleinement je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre
je vous remercie pour le groupe horizon
le président Marc Angeli pour une durée
de 10 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement mes chers
collègues nous sommes le lundi 12 juin
2023 et de quoi parlons-nous encore et
toujours de la réforme des retraites
soit 3 mois après l'adoption définitive
de la réforme par le Parlement plus de 5
mois après que la première ministre est
présentée ce texte et plus de 8 mois
près le début des cycles de concertation
menée par le gouvernement nous parlons
toujours de la réforme des retraites
sans compter qu'il y a neuf jours à
peine les premiers décrets d'application
de la réforme ont été publiés au Journal
officiel permettez-moi tout d'abord au
nom du groupe que je préside de déplorer
le manque criant de proposition de fonds
alternatives dans les débats de ces
dernières semaines nous avons
malheureusement plus été occupé à parler
méthodes et techniques parlementaires
qu'autre chose
à la place nous nous sommes concentrés
sur la question de l'application ou la
non-application du fameux article 40 de
la Constitution à la proposition de loi
émanant du groupe lot dans l'espoir de
revenir sur ce qui était déjà acté
certains semblent avoir du mal avec les
règles de nos institutions et refuse de
reconnaître leurs défaites quitte à
mentir à nos concitoyable mentir car
personne sur ses bancs ne pouvait
ignorer que cette proposition de loi
aurait créé une charge supplémentaire
pour les finances publiques de notre
pays une charge d'autant plus lourde
qu'elle conservait les 7 milliards
d'euros prévus par la réforme des
retraites pour réparer des situations
injustes par de nouveaux progrès sociaux
on a connu mieux en matière de sérieux
budgétaire
l'intangibilité de la réalité la voici
vous protestez nous respectons la lettre
des textes qui régissent la Cinquième
République c'est aussi simple que ça
l'ensemble des procédures parlementaires
prévues ont été respectées du début à la
fin et vous le contestez parce que le
résultat n'est pas conforme à vos
attentes
j'en veux pour preuve il y a encore
quelques jours un vote a eu lieu à la
commission des affaires sociales
auxquelles l'intégralité de ses membres
et bien au-delà d'ailleurs on prépare
ils ont voté majoritairement la
suppression du premier article de cette
proposition de loi qui abrogé le recul
de l'âge de départ à la retraite avant
cela lorsque la première ministre a
engagé la responsabilité de son
gouvernement sur la réforme des
retraites et des députés d'opposition
déposées une motion de censure appelant
à faire un vote contre le texte cette
motion n'a pas été adoptée et encore
avant la réforme des retraites avait
fait l'objet d'un vote favorable au
Sénat avant un accord en commission
mixte paritaire
il y a donc eu au moins trois votes sur
ce texte qui sont autant de défaites
pour les oppositions bien loin du déni
de démocratie ou de la mise en péril de
la démocratie parlementaire comme
l'affirme les signataires de cette
notion de censure avec en phase
j'observe d'ailleurs que ceux qui crient
au déni de démocratie aujourd'hui était
hier les premiers à pratiquer
l'obstruction parlementaire notamment
pour empêcher un vote sur le report de
l'âge de départ à la retraite sans doute
saisi d'une soudaine peur du résultat
comme d'habitude que dire également de
l'étrange alliance de circonstances
liées à l'occasion de l'examen de cette
proposition de loi faudrait dessus en
déduire que les oppositions dans leur
diversité et leur contradictions sont
prêtes à gouverner ensemble existe-t-il
une autre majorité que celle-ci capable
de gouverner notre pays dans un moment
charnière de notre histoire la réponse
est deux fois non mes chers collègues
car les manœuvres législatif réalisé à
des fins purement politiciennes
desservent grandement les travaux menés
par notre assemblée pire elles abîme
notre démocratie tâchons d'être digne du
mandat que les ça nous en confié et
répondons à leurs attentes celle du
pouvoir d'achat avec le projet de loi à
venir sur le partage de la valeur de
justice avec une hausse des moyens
humains et financiers dédiée de santé
avec la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux comment ne pas mentionner
également le projet de loi pour le plein
d'emploi qui facilitera bientôt un
retour à l'activité pour ceux qui en
sont éloignés les chantiers sont
nombreux ambitieux et bien souvent
indispensables nous devons les mener à
bien pour répondre au sentiment
d'impuissance publique qui traverse
notre pays la recherche de la
conflictualité permanente doit laisser
place à l'apaisement et à la
construction la responsabilité doit
reprendre le pas sur la radicalité c'est
ainsi que loin des populismes et du
déclinisme nos idées aux démocratiques
seront préservées c'est pourquoi il est
plus que jamais impératif d'avoir un
gouvernement à la tâche qui œuvre pour
l'intérêt de nos concitoyens pour ces
raisons les députés du groupe horizon et
apparentés vous renouvelle leur soutien
madame la Première ministre et ne
voteront pas cette motion de censure je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
la parole est à madame la Présidente
châtelain pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues on l'a
répété parfois trop parfois mauvais
escient la démocratie n'est ni en été
mise en état de fait ni à Rock
indestructible et il nous faut faire
face aujourd'hui au menaces qu'il a mine
le 22 juin 2022 des militants d'extrême
droite frappent et jette des pierres aux
participants de la Marche des fiertés à
Bordeaux le 21 octobre une centaine de
personnes cagoulées et menaçantes ont
décidé dans des rues de Lyon scandant
des slogans racistes le 7 décembre 30
militants d'extrême droite armée de
matraques télescopique on violemment
interrompu la réunion publique tenue par
les députés car le spartens belongo et
Louis Boyard dans la nuit de mardi un
mercredi 8 février 2023 les locaux du
planning familial de la Gironde ont été
vandalisés par une attaque d'un groupe
d'un groupe Usul d'extrême droite le 7
mars des slogans antivégés sont peints
sur le planning familial de Strasbourg
le le 11 mars une cinquantaine de
militants d'ultra-droite on défilé dans
le premier arrondissement de Lyon pour
intimider celles et ceux qui ne
partagent pas leurs idées le 6 mai 500
manifestants d'extrême droite vêtus de
noir et cagoulés ont défilé à Paris dans
la nuit du mardi 16 mai défilé
nationalistes a eu lieu dans les rues
d'Annecy jeudi dernier alors qu'hansie
traverse une épreuve terrible que la
France est sous le choc les groupuscules
radicalisés d'extrême droite parcourent
la ville et à Paris le guide organise un
planning raciste ce week-end à clairvolé
lacs un tract néo-nazi antisémite
homophobe et faisant l'apologie de la
Reine Blanche a été distribuée ce
week-end le service d'ordre de
reconquête à roué de coups un élu
écologiste la liste est longue bien trop
longue et elle est loin d'être complète
nationaliste néopaschiste néo-nazi
catholique intégrist rassemblement
national reconquête l'extrême droite à
plusieurs visages mais elle a une haine
commune la haine de l'autre la haine de
celles et ceux qui ne pensent pas comme
eux la haine de celles et ceux qui ne
vivent pas comme eux la haine reste
l'unique programme de l'extrême droite
nombre d'entre vous dans cet assemblée
ont été faibles vous avez été faible
quand vous avez repris les mots de
l'extrême droite vous avez été faible
quand vous avez repris leurs idées
aujourd'hui à cause de vous l'extrême
droite se sont puissante
alors je veux reprendre les mots de
Christiane trebira et je veux dire à
l'extrême droite vous finirez seul et
vaincus car longue longue et la mémoire
vous finirez seuls et vaincus car
invincible et notre ardeur
madame la Première ministre avoue je
souhaite dire une fois n'est pas coutume
vous avez raison le rassemblement
national et l'héritier de Pétain si le
président de la République vous a
reproché ces mots sachez qu'ici à
l'Assemblée nationale vous pourrez
toujours compter sur les progressistes
pour aller rappeler la généalogie de
l'extrême droite
mais rappelez la tâche rappeler la tâche
originelle de la création du parti
d'extrême droite n'est pas suffisant
lorsque les milices d'extrême droite
s'organisent dans nos villes c'est la
démocratie qui est en danger toutes
celles et tous ceux qui défendent la
République doivent donc être exemplaires
ils doivent être intransigents jamais
ils ne doivent céder sur le plan des
valeurs jamais il ne doivent affaiblir
nos institutions et sur ce point madame
la Première ministre vous et votre
gouvernement avait échoué s'il vous
plaît la CFDT la CGT est faux CFE-CGC la
CFTC l'unza solidaire l'afsu lunettes la
machine le mouvement national lycéen
sont unis et vous les avez ignorés cette
Français sur 10 sont opposés à la
réforme des retraites des millions
d'entre eux ont marché dans la rue ils
ont perdu des jours de travail et vous
les avez méprisés
l'Assemblée nationale est opposée à
cette réforme mais par deux fois vous
l'avez empêché de voter alors le doute
s'installe nous institutions
fonctionnent-elles suis-je réellement
représentée à cela se la sert de voter
au nom de qui le gouvernement prend-il
des décisions au nom des Français ou des
marchés financiers le doute se propage
Émile peu à peu la confiance qui est le
fondement même de notre République
confiance entre le peuple et ses
institutions confiance entre les
citoyens et leurs élus je reste
décrivait la République dans son
discours à la jeunesse en 1903 la
République c'est un grand tac de
confiance instituer la République ses
propres clamé que des millions d'hommes
seront tracés eux-mêmes la règle commune
de leur action qu'ils seront concilier
la liberté la loi le mouvement et l'Orne
qu'ils seront se combattent sans se
déchirer la perte de confiance est
toujours la première étape ou
démantèlement de l'État de droit elle
est le ferment des régimes et libéraux
la confiance est donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'il y a de plus précieux dans le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
mais à chaque lit d'hôpital qui ferme la
confiance aussi à chaque enfant
confronté à une école sans moyens la
confiance vacille à chaque nouvelle
procédure judiciaire contrairement de
votre gouvernement madame la Première
ministre la confiance faite arrangement
avec les usages de notre assembier la
confiance s'effrite à chaque article de
la Constitution utilisé contre les
Français la confiance trébuche ni vous
ni le président ne vous comportez en
garant des institutions vous vous
comportez en propriétaire vous
considérez que nos institutions sont au
service de votre idéologie de votre
programme vous êtes persuadé d'y tenir
la vérité mais vous ne faites plus de la
politique vous êtes parti en croisade
vous voulez faire prospérer coûte que
coûte un modèle capitaliste contre les
communs contre les Français condamnant
leur présent et leur futur
et pour nous convaincre du bien fondé de
votre mission vous faites votre le credo
de Margaret Thatcher il n'y a pas
d'arternative un Français sur cinq
n'arrive plus à se nourrir correctement
15 millions de personnes sont impactées
par la crise du logement empruntons
l'eau manquait déjà dans plusieurs
communes françaises 80% des insectes ont
disparu en 30 ans Bernardo a une fortune
équivalente à celle cumulée de près de
20 millions de Français françaises mais
il n'y a pas d'alternative vous refusez
le changement de modèle agricole vous
refusez l'ISF climatique vous refusez de
bloquer les prix des produits de
première nécessité pour refuser
d'interdire Virtu jet privé vous refusez
de redonner des moyens en bailleurs
sociaux vous refusez d'investir
massivement dans la rénovation thermique
et il n'y a pas d'alternative madame
borne n'existe pas d'internative il n'y
a plus de politique possible il n'y a
plus d'alternance possible il y a d'un
côté celles et ceux qui détiennent la
vérité de l'autre ce qui monte une
vision que je pourrais résumer en
quelques mots vous êtes avec nous ou
contre nous mais soyons réalistes
personne ne détient la vérité ni vous ni
nous seuls les prophètes les fous les
monarques prétendent détenir la vérité
écoutez les oppositions démocratiques
cette leçon de censure est un message
adressé en français et en particulier au
plus jeune on leur dit le combat
continue ne perdez pas confiance nous
députés de la nupette nous abrogerons la
réforme des retraites nous députés de la
nupette nous défendrons nos institutions
nous modifierons le référendum
d'initiative partagée pour qu'il puisse
être réellement mis en œuvre nous
supprimerons le 49-3 nous mettrons en
place la proportionnelle nous ferons
exploser cette devoir dans laquelle le
président et le gouvernement se sont
enfermés nous mettrons en place une
transition écologique pour la France et
mettons notre diplomatie au service de
transformation ambitieuse en Europe et
dans le monde la dégradation de notre
environnement nous frappe déjà il suffit
juste de jeter un oeil de l'autre côté
de l'Atlantique pour voir la ville qui
ne dort jamais suffoquer sous les fumées
d'incendie qui ravagent le Canada ou
simplement de regarder chez nous les
inondations et les coulées de doux les
urgences sont trop grandes trop
importantes trop dangereuses pour que
nous fabissions nous n'en n'avons pas le
droit mais jamais les solutions ne
pourront venir d'un seul homme
enfin je souhaiterais rappeler la phrase
de Mister Churchill la démocratie et le
pire des systèmes à l'exclusion de tous
les autres et j'y ajouterai une
condition c'est qu'elle soit toujours
utilisée au service des Français pour
qu'enfin ce soit les Français qui
gagnent
madame la Présidente je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Hubert vulfran
pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
demander la censure du gouvernement pour
un être qu'un énième acte à l'encontre
de la politique de l'exécutif mais cette
motion de censure et bien plus que
l'expression d'un désaccord elle est
désormais la seule option qui nous est
offerte par une constitution au service
quasi exclusif du pouvoir exécutif pour
tenter de mettre un terme à
l'autoritarisme de votre pouvoir
le jeudi 8 juin démonstration a été
faite par l'entremise de quelques
piètres amendements de la fiction sur
laquelle repose la Cinquième République
la fameuse séparation des pouvoirs
consacré par l'article 16 de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen ainsi reçu la plus magistrale
des baffes une gifle qui a été
administrée par la présidente même de
l'Assemblée nationale au représentant du
peuple et donc aux Français
à la page des procédures pour étouffer
les initiatives des oppositions sera
désormais inscrite dans le fameux
registre des précédents de notre
assemblée ce jeudi noir pour notre
démocratie un parlementarisme toujours
plus dévitalisé au fil des réformes de
notre Constitution avec déjà mis un mal
cette séparation des pouvoirs elle est
pourtant un instrument de limitation de
l'arbitraire les dates clés de cette
dérive structurelle qui nous ont conduit
à la fiction de la séparation des
pouvoirs sont connus élection du
président de la République au suffrage
universel direct entre 32 instauration
du quinquennat en 2000 et inversion du
calendrier électoral en 2001 les
artisans de ces réformes n'ont
certainement pas imaginé que cette
constitution serait au service un jour
d'un président qui se rêve à la fois
Jupiter et mettre des horloges et
qu'illustrerait de manière caricaturale
la logique présidentialiste qu'importe
pour vous aujourd'hui puisque Emmanuel
Macron
une autre étant préparation nous dit-on
mais nous devons avouer que nous restons
encore sans voix abasourdi que ce coût a
pu être porté par la présidente même de
notre institution ne peignez pas de nous
faire croire qu'il s'agissait d'une
simple affaire de recevabilité
d'amendement nous le savons vous le
savez les Français le savent ce qui
s'est joué ce Jeudi Noir et le jour
précédent est une mise à mort en règle
du Parlement législateur en lui refusant
une de ces dernières facultés le droit
d'initiative parlementaire des
oppositions et des groupes minoritaires
en écartant dans le cadre d'une niche
parlementaire les amendements reprenant
une disposition déclarée deux fois
recevable vous avez réduit madame la
Présidente avec le soutien des groupes
de votre majorité et sur commande de
l'exécutif notre Parlement au silence
législatif c'est un acte d'anti
parlementarisme pur
c'est une première dans l'histoire de la
Cinquième République une condamnation à
l'impuissance législative prononcée par
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
elle-même et tout ça pourquoi parce que
le gouvernement n'était pas prêt à subir
le camouflet d'un vote de notre
assemblée sur la réforme des retraites
le report de l'âge légal de la retraite
à 64 ans le peuple n'en voulait pas il
n'en veut toujours pas et leur
représentant dans cette assemblée son
majoritaire pour ne pas en vouloir c'est
un fait les faits sont têtus
enfin insupportable pour un président
qui veut décider de tout tout seul tous
les articles de notre Constitution ont
été utilisés pour empêcher ce vote avec
succès mais sans succès mes chers
collègues pour notre démocratie est-ce
un succès que cette réforme des
retraites qui impacte avec violence les
plus fragiles d'entre nous ne soient pas
soumis au vote est-ce une victoire que
cette réforme qui obligera le français à
travailler plus longtemps jusqu'à 64 65
ans soit opposés imposé par le 49.3
êtes-vous fier ou tout simplement
lâchement soulagé d'avoir empêché à tout
prix le moindre Noël des représentants
du peuple sur le droit à une retraite
juste que des millions de Français
considèrent comme un droit inaliénable
vous sentez-vous haitier d'avoir refusé
l'obstacle face aux françaises et aux
Français qui ont défilé pendant des mois
par million dans la dignité de leur
colère
cette motion de censure vous offre la
possibilité mes chers collègues d'un
dernier sursaut saisissez-la refusez que
votre capacité d'action et pour laquelle
vous avez été élu soit réduite à peau de
chagrin refuser la confiscation par
l'exécutif du pouvoir législatif notre
Présidente nous le disons avec stupeur à
céder à la pression du président de la
République et du gouvernement refusons
d'y consentir refusons d'apporter la
moindre caution à cette capitulation
refusons d’être exclu de l'initiative
législative par simple responsabilité
vis-à-vis de nos électrices et de nos
électeurs mais aussi vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble du peuple français nous
devons conserver nos capacités d'agir
pour pouvoir proposer et voter des lois
qui défendent l'intérêt général
et non pas celui des plus riches des
plus puissants des plus proches du
pouvoir eux ils ont leur représentants
ils les ont dans toutes les autres
sphères du pouvoir ils n'ont pas besoin
de battre le pavé pour faire entendre
leur voix par le vote de cette motion de
censure montrez-leur que vous avez enfin
compris y compris vous les membres de la
majorité si peu nombreux cet après-midi
le méza le message qu'il vous a envoyé
en juin 2022 en refusant un pouvoir sans
partage au président de la République
ce régime de cumule et de confusion des
pouvoirs concentrer à l'extrême à
l'Élysée les Français ont voulu y mettre
un terme lors des élections législatives
de 2022 en ne désignant qu'une majorité
toute relative en soutien à Emmanuel
Macron ils ont clairement exprimé leur
refus de
présidentialisme qui a fixé notre
démocratie leur volonté était claire il
faut rééquilibrer et séparer les
pouvoirs alors mes chers collègues
censureront sérieusement ce gouvernement
des aujourd'hui pour que plus jamais
notre assemblée ne soit censuré merci
vous nous avez remerciés madame la
Première ministre merci madame la
Première ministre de permettre aux
député de pouvoir disposer de cette
ultime choix au moment où cette victoire
votre victoire soi-disant à la Pyrrhus
signe en même temps la dissolution
définitive du macronisme
je vous remercie
la parole
[Musique]
est à monsieur le Président penchère
pour le groupe libertin indépendant
outre-mer et territoire
alors le président penchère n'est pas
présent dans l'hémicycle donc
l'oratrice suivante
qui est la madame Amélia la crafi pour
le groupe Renaissance
alors ça bouleverse
l'ordre du jour pour le rassemblement
national est-ce que madame Julie le
chanteur est présente est-ce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour allez un petit lance on écoute
madame Julie le chanteur pour une durée
de 15 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame le
Premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues
pourquoi avez-vous peur de débattre
pourquoi avez-vous peur du Parlement
pourquoi avez-vous peur de voter et
faire voter pourquoi avez-vous peur du
peuple pourquoi avez-vous peur des
Français tout simplement
pourtant vous n'hésitez jamais à asséner
que vous avez été lu par eux que votre
mandat est issu d'une majorité somme
toute relative du peuple votant pourtant
vous tremblez vous tremblez comme des
feuilles mortes d'un sombre matin
d'automne
vous bafouez les droits les plus
élémentaires du parlementarisme en
musulmans les oppositions et a priori ça
vous fait sourire le respect des
oppositions parlons-en tout en souriant
et n'écoutant pas outre le fait de
garantir la vie démocratique permet
aussi de légiférer dans un climatisé en
essayant de bâtir des compromis au nom
de la nation au nom du peuple peuple un
mot que vous méconnez que vous méprisez
que vous ignorez la preuve encore la
minorité est présidentielle que vous
incarnez n'a eu de cesse de renvoyer les
Français Doha do de pratiquer le deux
poids de mesure les retraités contre les
actifs les jeunes contre les moins
jeunes les salariés contre les chômeurs
les patrons contre les employés les
vaccinés contre les non vaccinés vous
gouvernez par la dissection de la
société française vous gouvernez par
omission vous gouverner en étant
constamment fort avec les plus précaires
et faibles avec les plus fortunés le
peuple français dans sa grande sagesse
ne vous a pas donné de majorité absolue
sentant la dangerosité d'un tel cas de
figure à chaque fois qu'il a tenté de
vous rappeler vos devoirs vous avez été
sourd à chaque fois qu'il a tenté de
vous dire ce dont il avait besoin vous
avez fait au mieux la sourde oreille au
pire exact opposé le peuple vous demande
de ne pas alourdir les carrières des
Français les années de cotisation et
l'âge du départ à la retraite résultat
vous passez en force une réforme
autoritaire de cas social les Français
vous demandent d'arrêter l'immigration
massive et incontrôlée d'expulser les
auqtf et de renvoyer les étrangers
délinquant chez eux résultat vous
accueillis vous accueillez l'Océane
Viking vous ouvrez les ports français
vous peupler nos villes et nos villages
de millions de migrants dont on ne sait
ni qui ils sont ni doux ils viennent 500
000 par an ça fait plus plusieurs
millions faut relire vos fiches
nos frontières sont évidemment et
malheureusement devenus de véritables
passoires les Français vous demandent
protection et sécurité nous avons des
viols des meurtres des attaques et des
vols avec violence au quotidien vous
râlez il suffit de penser à Annecy et il
vous demande les Français des systèmes
de protection de l'économie nationale et
une baisse de l'inflation nous avons un
tissu de TPME
fragilisé par le coup de l'énergie une
inflation qui explose le record du
déficit de la balance commerciale et la
plus forte dette de la Cinquième
République les Français vous demandent
une école où l'on apprend où l'on
développe sa culture générale et l'amour
de la France vous détruisez l'école
républicaine en faisant de cette
institution un repère des pires
dérivoquistes ou les racailles et les
harceleurs terrorisent les élèves
les Français vous demandent de soutenir
leur pouvoir d'achat vous refusez de
baisser la TVA sur les énergies et de la
supprimer sur les produits de première
nécessité vous préférez créer un
dispositif de chèques qui lui nourrit
l'inflation les Français vous demandent
une baisse des impôts vous les
multipliez pour les français quand dans
le même temps vous financez tous les
dispositifs possibles et inimaginables
pour les étrangers et les pays étrangers
avec une régularité constante et
parfaitement inquiétante vous agissez
ainsi contre le peuple à chaque fois
49-3 47 1 vote bloqué et maintenant
l'article 40 vous avez eu recours à
toutes les manœuvres constitutionnelles
pour agir contre le peuple et lui voler
brutalement deux ans de retraite deux
ans de vie le Pape a désormais a
désormais l'habitude de vos combines de
votre méthode de gouverner de votre
haine farouche du débat parlementaire il
vous le montre au quotidien sur les
marchés lors de vos déplacements enfin
quand les Français ont le droit d'être
présent d'ailleurs sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les manifestations mais il
y a aussi il y a aussi une majorité
silencieuse qui ne se manifeste pas
forcément mais qui souffrent en silence
et qui aspire à un changement total
bref
depuis un an notre groupe rassemblement
national
incarne une force d'apaisement que les
Français réclament nous incarnons la
démocratie avec la volonté de faire des
référendum nous incarnons un véritable
projet de justice et d'équité sociale
avec nous
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler avant
20 ans partiront à 60 ans avec 48 à
nuités puis progressivement jusqu'à 62
ans avec 42 à nuités en 2027 Marine Le
Pen abrogera cette injuste réforme des
retraites elle rétablira la paix sociale
et rendra le pouvoir au peuple
à tous les Français qui ne croient plus
on nous institutions nous voulons dire
qu'il n'y a pas de fatalité car une
alternat une alternative responsable est
possible contrairement à ce que ce
gouvernement veut nous faire croire
cette alternance est la seule chance que
nous avons de redresser notre pays et de
rétablir l'ordre avec nous les Français
décideront directement des sujets
cruciaux à commencer par celui de
l'immigration sujet sur lequel vos
résultats sont catastrophiques en 2022
vous avez offert le gîte le couvert et
tous les soins gratuits à 320 000
migrants c'est l'équivalent de la ville
de Nice pendant ce temps-là vous
abandonnez
300100 domicile fixes et 11 millions de
Français en situation de pauvreté qui ne
parviennent ni à se nourrir ni à se
loger ni à se soigner
plutôt que de combattre les vrais
problèmes que nous rencontrons les vrais
problèmes que subissent les Français
votre seul obsession est de combattre le
rassemblement national c'est votre seul
et unique programme le grand écart entre
la droite et la gauche apporter ses
fruits vous avez pris le pire des deux
vous les avez mélangés et vous en avez
fait un cocktail horriblement dégoûtant
pour la France et les Français
[Applaudissements]
pourtant le rassemblement national et
pour les Français le premier rempart
face à toutes les gabegie
gouvernementales face à votre politique
autoritaire et violente face à vos
idéologies néfastes nous n'avons qu'une
seule boussole qu'un seul objectif
garantir aux Français leurs droits leur
liberté et leur sécurité car voilà le
projet politique de la macronie poussez
eux les limites de la brutalité afin de
la rendre acceptable vos leçons
grassement payées auprès de cabinets de
conseils qui vous servent uniquement à
étouffer par le chantage et la peur les
revendications les plus élémentaires des
Français madame le Premier ministre ce
chaos que vous souhaitez éviter en
maîtrisant le débat parlementaire ne le
voyez vous pas déjà
les français eux ils le voient et
surtout ils le subissent quotidiennement
nous ne voulons plus de votre
aveuglement nous ne voulons plus de
votre brutalité nous ne voulons plus de
votre stratégie de la peur à l'heure de
voter cette motion chers collègues
députés du groupe LR très peu nombreux
très peu de courageux après avoir permis
l'élection des manuels Macron
ne restez pas une nouvelle fois
spectateur de l'histoire et surtout
complice de la minorité présentielle
ayez la France au cœur ne soyez pas une
nouvelle fois la béquille d'un
gouvernement éculé la béquille d'un
gouvernement qui met notre démocratie à
genoux le groupe rassemblement national
fort de sa ligne de conduite inchangée
dont j'ai l'honneur de porter la voix et
la parole aujourd'hui prendra lui une
nouvelle fois ses responsabilités et
votera au nom du peuple qui a mis ce
gouvernement en minorité la motion de
censure qui nous occupe et si cette
motion devait aboutir à une dissolution
nous nous sommes prêts aux élections car
nous n'avons pas peur du peuple
[Applaudissements]
j'invite enfin les vrais patriotes les
députés sincères de tout bon ce qui
écoute les Français dans leur
circonscription respective à voter la
motion de censure de ce jour je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
donc on va revenir en arrière dans
l'ordre des prises de parole et la
parole est à Monsieur Bertrand pencher
pour le groupe liotte pour une durée de
10 minutes
merci beaucoup madame merci beaucoup
madame la présidente Madame la madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
la messieurs les ministres chers
collègues
depuis moins d'un an madame la Première
ministre nous en sommes à 17 motion de
censure contre votre gouvernement 17 à
12 articles 49.3 et un chapelet
invraisemblable d'obstruction du
Parlement dans le cadre de votre projet
de loi sur les retraites un signe
évident de passage en force et
d'incapacité à construire du collectif
vous deviez apaiser le pays en 100 jours
et vous échouez pire chaque jour vous
divisez encore davantage notre pays
vous avez échoué à rassembler notre pays
il est plus que jamais divisé vous avez
échoué à respecter la démocratie la
Constitution le Parlement les corps
intermédiaires et les Français pires
vous avez cautionné et orchestré cette
attaque frontale contre l'Assemblée
nationale en nous empêchant de voter
notre proposition de loi sur les
retraites du jamais vu depuis le début
de la cinquième république vous avez
échoué à tenir vos promesses sur le
pouvoir d'achat la sécurité l'éducation
de logement la santé la préservation de
l'environnement votre triste bilan
madame la Première ministre c'est tout
celui c'est aussi celui d'Emmanuel
Macron il est patent vous avez dit
lapidé l'argent public s'en distingués
ceux qui avaient besoin de ceux qui
pouvaient faire des efforts les
entreprises du CAC 40 ou les gros
patrimoine et au final qui va trinquer
toujours les mêmes les classes moyennes
et les classes populaires résultat plus
600 milliards de dettes supplémentaires
pour notre pays en six ans commerce
extérieur qui continue à se dégrader
comme jamais depuis plus de 60 ans
la plus importante augmentation des
défaillances d'entreprises dans notre
histoire depuis en 2022
des compatriotes qui ont de plus en plus
de mal à se faire soigner à se loger
beaucoup à se nourrir un pays qui a
perdu son leadership en Europe dans le
monde et qui est chassé d'Afrique
francophone un taux de chômage plus
élevé que la moyenne européenne alors
que la reprise économique est mondiale
et que vous radiez plus de 500000
chômeuses et chômeurs par an enfin notre
démocratie qui n'a jamais été aussi
affaibli depuis le début de la cinquième
république encore si vous restiez
modeste ou si vous faisiez un moment
d'honorable nos critiques seraient moins
Serbes on aurait même pu songer ils sont
de bonne volonté mais ils ne réussissent
toujours pas mais vous continuez dans
l'imodestie voir pour certains d'entre
vous dans l'arrogance et vous jetez
chaque jour un peu plus d'huile sur le
feu
les critiques sur votre méthode s'élève
même dans vos propres rangs je ne vous
apprends rien beaucoup nous ont
questionné pourquoi n'avons pas déposé
notre propre motion de censure le boulet
n'était pas passé loin la dernière fois
nous ne voulons nous ne voulions pas que
vous puissiez mentir à nouveau en
déclarant qu'il y avait eu juste eu un
vote sur les retraites j'ajoute que ce
mode de scrutin est injuste et qu'il ne
prend pas en compte les abstentions au
fond il faudrait ajouter à ceux qui
votent la motion de censure ceux qui ne
sont pas là et qui boycottent le vote
nous pensons madame la Première ministre
que vous devriez tirer vous-même les
conclusions qui s'imposent vont votre
responsabilité désormais serait de
démissionner madame la Première ministre
c'est le meilleur service que vous
pourriez rendre à notre pays il ne
s'agit pas là d'une attaque personnelle
mais vous êtes clairement
identifié maintenant comme la
représentante d'un système
technocratique et de concentration des
pouvoirs qui s'imaginent que l'on peut
gouverner sans le Parlement sans les
corps intermédiaires et sans le peuple
votre démission démontrerait que vous
auriez compris le caractère
indispensable d'une nouvelle gouvernance
de nouvelles méthodes de décision d'un
nouveau mode de gouvernement plus
démocratique la clé de réussite pour
notre pays le président Macron avait
gagné les élections en 2017 avec comme
slogan rassemblé les Françaises et les
Français au-delà des cultures partisanes
et traditionnelles et il avait raison
mais il a fait tout le contraire il a
des bouchers ici à droite ici à gauche
pour affaiblir ses camps et non pas pour
rassembler
son projet cette conserver le pouvoir
plutôt que de le redonner à nos
compatriotes c'est le contraire qu'il
faut faire c'est à quoi nous voulons
nous employer tous avec modestie
évidemment mais avec des terminations
car les défis de la France sont immenses
et pour les relevés il nous faut une
vraie vision un nouveau projet une autre
méthode et surtout surtout redonner la
confiance à nos concitoyens le malaise
de notre société c'est de vivre dans un
système bloqué technocratisé hyper
centralisée tout est lié fragilité de
notre économie technocratie parisienne
étouffante enfin archaïsme et
conservatif dans notre modèle
démocratique un système verrouillé qui
donne une société bloquée pourtant que
notre français belle est forte de sa
diversité de ces territoires il faut
écouter et agir avec tous ceux qui
pendant le covid ont permis d'accueillir
les enfants des personnels hospitaliers
ont ouvert des centres de vaccination
ont apporté des vivres françaises alors
même que l'État patauger à fournir des
masques à nos concitoyens les mêmes qui
chaque jour font face à une
réglementation toujours plus
contraignante alors que même leurs
moyens diminue la réforme des retraites
a démontré encore une fois l'absence
totale d'écoute des corps intermédiaires
du Parlement et de l'opinion publique il
est urgent de réformer en profondeur nos
méthodes de décision par un triple choc
décentralisé c'est-à-dire donner le
pouvoir d'agir aux élus locaux gouvernés
au plus proche des territoires et des
populations transférées massivement les
compétences et les champs d'intervention
de l'État chaque fois que cela s'avère
plus efficace comme dans tous les pays
qui nous entourent redonner le pouvoir à
nos concitoyens afin qu'ils fassent
remonter eux-mêmes leur priorité au plan
national et local leur permettre enfin
de prendre leur destin en main et de
faire que nous décidions ensemble pour
cela il nous faut généraliser le recours
et référendum
d'ailleurs l'engagement du président
Macron il s'était engagé encore une
promesse non tenue
rééquilibrer les pouvoirs au sommet de
l'État afin que les décisions ne soient
plus prises par le seul président de la
République et son entourage cela passe
par redonner le pouvoir au Parlement
pouvoir que vous nous avez confisqué
celui que vous nous avez confisqué
pendant les retraites il faut en finir
avec l'endogamie technocratique cet État
dans l'État cela passe par le respect et
le renouvellement de nos institutions
nous allons y travailler pour construire
une démocratie modernisée et renforcée
face à une technocratie parisienne
sclérosée nos concitoyens ont besoin de
confiance de pouvoir choisir et de
décider il veut être ils veulent tous
être utile pour notre pays face un CAC
40 qui détruit des emplois il nous faut
soutenir davantage nos PME TPE
entreprise intermédiaire et artisans qui
crée de la valeur et des emplois nous
avons besoin d'un nouveau pacte
entrepreneurial à la française pour
protéger et aider les intérêts des
petites entreprises il faut accélérer
accélérer le développement de nos PME
PMI des entreprises artisanales en
assouplissant leurs règles
administratives et les différencier de
celle des grands groupes il faut
réconcilier agriculteurs écologistes
pour une transition écologiste partagée
cela passe évidemment par des revenus
stables octroyants aux paysans en
prenant en compte les efforts qu'ils
font pour notre environnement cela passe
aussi par un soutien à la ruralité en
développant les services publics face à
l'urgence écologique nous avons besoin
d'une écologie des territoires
créatrices d'emploi de pouvoir d'achat à
quand le chèque alimentaire si souvent
promis qui permettrait de lier
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat et le
soutien à nos agriculteurs la planète
brûle et les actions ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux tant au niveau
national que européen ou international
et pourtant les politiques plus
cohérentes seraient créatrices de
davantage d'emploi de pouvoir d'achat de
bien-être de développement et de
réconciliation nationale la difficulté
n'est pas tant de prendre des décisions
à Paris que d'associer enfin toutes
celles et se concerner pour aboutir à
des objectifs simples et atteignables en
simplifiant la véritable priorité c'est
celle d'embarquer tout le monde le pire
étant de parler d'écologie et de ne rien
faire voir de multiplier des textes de
loi qui s'empilent nos politiques
structurelles énergies logement
transport agriculture au biodiversité
manque de stabilité de lisibilité dans
le temps de moyens et de clarté nous ne
devons ni opposer écologie progrès car
l’écologie des territoires est un
progrès ni nous réfugier dans des
politiques de décroissance qui
n'aideraient que les plus riches face à
une technocratie triomphante qui étouffe
notre pays il faut redonner de la
liberté respecter la dignité de chacun
de mettre les différences et les
particularités humaniser les rapports
entre l'administration et les
administraits et en un mot transformer
la vie quotidienne par une nouvelle
démocratie modernisée la prospérité est
nécessaire pour édifier une société
meilleure elle n'est pas suffisante tant
que nous ne partageons pas les mêmes
ambitions humaines les valeurs qui nous
ont réunies dans notre pays liberté
égalité fraternité sont devenus
abstraites elles ont perdu leur sens
c'est à nous qu'il appartient de les
réenchanter à travers un destin commun
une réalité nouvelle concrète un
développement enfin humain pour pousser
toutes économique sociale et
environnementale
il n'est jamais trop tard madame la
Première ministre chers collègues pour
bien faire nous sommes ici pour quatre
ans encore que de réformes à initier et
j'espère ensemble si nous nous en
donnons les moyens mais pour cela il n'y
a qu'une méthode écoutez écoutez écoutez
se respecter se respecter se respecter
ce que vous ne savez pas faire et bien
formulons-le veut qu'à travers peut-être
des électrochocs comme cette rencontre
aujourd'hui et bien vous puissiez enfin
comprendre qu'il est possible de
développer le pays et de développer le
pays ensemble vive la république et vive
la france merci beaucoup président pas
cher
la parole est à Madame Amélia la crafi
pour le groupe renaissance pour une
durée de 50 minutes
merci
madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
c'est le nombre de motions de censure
examinée depuis juin 2022 autant
d'occasions pour la représentation
nationale d'affirmer encore et encore
son soutien au gouvernement d'Elisabeth
borne car rappelons tout ont été rejetés
autant d'échecs pour l'extrême droite
comme pour l'extrême gauche qui malgré
leur volonté de faire oeuvre commune ne
parviennent pas à constituer une
majorité alternative celle-ci la 17e ne
fera pas exception elle sera rejetée
une fois de plus nous sommes ici pour
faire face ensemble une fois de plus le
gouvernement obtiendra la confiance de
l'Assemblée nationale et poursuivra son
action en faveur des Françaises et des
Français une fois de plus le
rassemblement national et la nups
uniront leur voix dans un mariage de
circonstances qui nous est désormais
bien familier et poursuivrons leur
entreprise populiste au service de même
et de seul car il s'agit bien ici d'une
stratégie politique
délibérée visant à entraver notre
travail et à créer du désordre nous
avons été élus ici pour servir la nation
pour faire passer les intérêts de nos
constituants avant les calculs
politiques
déposer d'émotions de censure et le
signe d'une démocratie vivante cet outil
prévu par notre Constitution pour
assurer l'équilibre des pouvoirs est
essentiel à la vitalité de nos
institutions
et pour ceux qui me concerne j'ai
toujours reconnu et respecter le rôle de
l'opposition son travail est crucial
précieux même mais mais dans le cas
d'espèces la raison d'être de la motion
a été totalement dénaturée pour en faire
un objet de déstabilisation systématique
tout ce qui est excessif est
insignifiant et en l'utilisant avec
excès vous avez contribué à en affaiblir
la portée
vous voulez faire de l'Assemblée
nationale un lieu où on ne légifère plus
vous voulez en faire une vitrine pour
vos coups d'éclats et au milieu de ce
spectacle qui personnellement me désole
quelle est la réalité de leur bilan
parlementaire à ma droite nous avons le
rassemblement national la devanture a
changé mais le fonds de commerce est le
même les députés ARN se veulent
respectables et font tout pour le
paraître au moins en façade mais les
vieilles postures et biologiques ont bel
et bien perdurer
banalisation des invectives xénophobes
remis en cause de la science et de
l'engagement des citoyens vaccinés
allégeance compromettante à une
puissance étrangère pleinement révélée
par la commission d'enquête qu'il a
lui-même sollicité voilà le sombre
héritage que le groupe de Marine Le Pen
veut laisser à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce l'image que nous souhaitons
présenter de notre démocratie de notre
pays nos concitoyens et au reste du
monde
toute ma vie j'ai lutté pour ne pas être
empêché dans mon parcours par les
clichés et les idées reçues délétères
que vous répondez aujourd'hui je suis
fière de le dire en tant que député
français ce qui aime ardemment la nation
croyez bien que j'aurai sans cesse à
cœur de faire barrage avec mon groupe
politique de l'autre côté de l'hémicycle
ensuite nous trouvons cette improbable
union des gauches une somme de désaccord
fondamentaux peut donner lieu à une
victoire électorale mais jamais à
l'émergence d'une vision commune pour la
France et les Français d'ailleurs il n'y
a aucune proposition tangible portée par
la nupette pour permettre à notre pays
de faire face aux défis qu'il doit
relever les divergences sur les sujets
les plus structurants sont bien
profondes aucune convergence sur
l'Europe la politique énergétique pas
plus sur notre stratégie économique en
réalité vous n'êtes d'accord sur rien
tous ici en dehors de cette hémicycle
avant était témoin de votre volonté de
faire obstruction au débat sur la
réforme des retraites de cette début
d'année
celles et ceux qui ont suivi il y a deux
semaines l'examen en commission de la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Charles de Gauchon ont pu constater
votre attitude ou transfert et vos
manœuvres désespérées déni de vote sur
le rejet de l'abrogation de la réforme
des peaux de centaines de sous
amendements à la va-vite retrait d'une
partie du texte par le rapporteur
lui-même vous êtes une volonté
d'obstruction et de chaos manifeste tout
cela n'est pas sérieux et surtout
contribue à abîmer l'image de notre
assemblée et vous que vous avez déjà
bien écornée depuis 12 mois
tout ceci
c'est ici que je veux souligner notre
différence fondamentale nous dans cette
assemblée notre engagement ne procède
pas de notre ambition personnelle mais
ce que nous consommons
mais ce que nous considérons ce que nous
considérons comme indispensable à
l'intérêt de notre nation nous
œuvrons pour le peuple français et oui
et c'est aussi ce qui guide ce qui nous
guide dans nos actions et dans nos
réformes ainsi ainsi ainsi la récente
réforme de notre système de retraite n'a
pas été réalisé par caprice ou par désir
de popularité mais parce qu'elle était
nécessaire elle était nécessaire c'est
notre devoir envers les générations
futures de garantir leur droit à la
retraite nous n'avions pas le droit
d'ignorer le péril qui menaçait le
régime par répartition aujourd'hui
ça cette nouvelle motion de censure nous
défendons nous défendons un gouvernement
qui a œuvré pour l'avenir et dans
l'intérêt de la nation en tant que
représentant de la République il est de
notre devoir de protéger nos
institutions et nos règles communes
piliers de notre démocratie garant de
nos droits
à ceux qui ont lancé cette motion jeudi
vos tentatives pour déstabiliser le
gouvernement ne font que renforcer notre
détermination à servir le peuple
français vos tactiques politiques ne
font qu'accentuer l'importance de notre
travail et le besoin de rester concentré
sur nos missions ce gouvernement a fait
preuve de résilience face à de très
nombreux défis je salue à cet égard la
solidité et la détermination de notre
première ministre nous avons eu le
courage d'engager des réformes
nécessaires bien que parfois impopulaire
nous avons travaillé avec une vision à
long terme
équilibrant la justice sociale et la
responsabilité financière
dans ces temps un certain nous avons
besoin de stabilité d'un leadership fort
et de confiance dans nos institutions
cette notion de censure n'apporte rien
de tout cela elle attise la méfiance et
le cynisme minant la confiance des
concitoyens dans leur représentants
ainsi en contemplant cette 17ème motion
je suis amené à rappeler une citation de
Churchill qui disait je cite le succès
consiste à aller chercher des chèques en
échec sans perdre son enthousiasme il
semble que l'enthousiasme de certains
pour l'échec est surpassé le bon sens
politique
c'est pourquoi je vous invite à une
profonde introspection sur les
conséquences de vos actions
considérez l'histoire
considérer le peuple qui nous a choisi à
quatre reprises pour le représenter et
rejeter encore une fois cette motion de
censure c'est à nous aujourd'hui de
choisir entre la persévérance dans
l'erreur et l'engagement envers notre
peuple pour ma part j'ai choisi
je vous remercie madame la députée
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la Présidente
pano pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre ministre scolaire
sommes-nous encore en démocratie en
macronie en macronie le président le
plus mal élu de la 5ème république
impose seul contre tout un peuple 2 ans
de vie volée en macronie une loi peut
passer en force sans aucune légitimité
parlementaire ni légitimité populaire en
macronie l'Assemblée nationale est
piétinée l'initiative parlementaire et
le droit d'amendement bafouis en
macronie les citoyens l'Inter syndical
les associations les représentants du
peuple ne comptent pour rien seul valent
les caprices du président auquel la
Nation toute entière doit se plier en
macronie on n'hésite pas à salir le
président de la commission des finances
Éric Coquerel pour protéger son camp
en macronie la démocratie est un luxe
dont nous devrions nous passer
sommes-nous encore en démocratie en
macronie quand celles et ceux qui
manifestent sont arrêtés arbitrairement
et réprimer sous les rappels à l'ordre
du rapporteur spécial au liberté de
l'ONU du Conseil de l'Europe de la
Commission nationale consultative des
droits humains de la LDH de la Défenseur
des droits ou encore d'Amnesty
internationale quand le droit de grève
est attaqué par des réquisitions
massives quand les représentants du
peuple sont empêchés de voter contre la
retraite à 64 ans article 47 ans 44 de
44 3 49.3 40 de la Constitution jamais
autant d'outils anti-démocratiques
n'avait été mobilisés en même temps dans
l'histoire de la Cinquième République
quand la séparation des pouvoirs n'est
plus feinte des ministres s'arrochent
tranquillement le droit de décider ce
que l'Assemblée nationale pourrait ou
non voter d'autres font pression sur des
parlementaires pour leur faire changer
leur vote
jusqu'à avoir l'indécence de mettre en
jeu l'existence d'une maternité
sommes-nous encore en démocratie en
macronie madame la Première ministre
vous avez bouché toutes les issues
démocratiques vous ne vous rendez même
plus compte des seuils que vous
franchissez gouvernés c'est assumer une
responsabilité devant l'histoire avec
vos méthodes vous ouvrez la porte du
pire le bras de fer d'Emmanuel Macron
contre le peuple de France et tout le
contraire de la démocratie dans son
contrat social Rousseau écrivait que la
puissance législative appartient au
peuple et ne peut appartenir qu'à lui
toute loi que le peuple en personne n'a
pas ratifié est nul et ce n'est point
une loi
sommes-nous encore en démocratie en
macronie en tout cas il semblerait que
nous ne soyons plus en république car la
République est avant tout social et
jamais aucun gouvernement avant vous
n'avez autant méprisé l'existence
humaine votre monde est devenu un océan
de malheur 6 ans d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
11 millions de nos concitoyens qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté dans la
septième puissance économique au monde
c'est la fin qui disloque le pays un
français sur 6 se prive d'un repas par
jour la vie chère étrangle les Français
c'est 12 millions de personnes qui
souffrent de la crise du logement c'est
un nombre de personnes sans domicile
fixe qui a doublé en 10 ans la France
connaît d'après l'Insee un coup de franc
sur les gains d'espérance de vie que le
covid ne suffit pas à expliquer
les ouvriers ont toujours six années
d'espérance de vie de moins que les
cadres la France et la triste championne
de l'hécatombe en Europe avec deux
salariés qui meurent chaque jour du
travail mais vous refusez toujours
d'augmenter les salaires de bloquer les
prix à la baisse de geler les loyers non
d'ailleurs vous préférez les augmenter
et avec votre réforme 15000 personnes
mourront avant leur retraite et non
devons donc pas un jour de leurs droits
au repos où est la République sociale
quand la seule fraternité que vous
éprouvez est à l'endroit des riches vos
amis les riches pour qui vous avez
transformé notre pays ont un véritable
paradis fiscal
2%, c'est ce que fait en impôt sur le
revenu les 370 plus grosses fortunes de
notre pays contre 50% pour les classes
moyennes et populaires chaque année et
cette année encore les entreprises du
CAC 40 battent des records de versement
de dividendes aux actionnaires mais les
Français devraient travailler deux ans
de plus pour payer les pots cassés de
vos cadeaux plus fortunés
sommes-nous encore en démocratie en
macronie en tout cas en république non
car la République est un régime de
liberté le droit à la vie privée à la
sûreté la liberté d'expression de
manifestation de presse ne sont pas des
accessoires
elle garantissent que les femmes et les
hommes de notre pays ne sont pas
seulement des consommateurs ou des
producteurs mais bien des citoyens
neuf lois liberticides en six ans des
attaques contre le droit de grève les
libertés associatives le droit de
manifester partout où des citoyens se
mobilisent pour une cause sociale pour
la survie du seul écosystème compatible
avec la vie humaine pour notre avenir
vous voyez des ennemis réductibles vous
ne tolérez pas la manifestation d'une
opposition dans la rue ou dans
l'assemblée sinon nous aurions voté
jeudi dernier l'abrogation de la réforme
des retraites à 64 ans
vous vous rassurez en vous disant que
c'est de la nuit pêche des gilets jaunes
des militants écologistes des militants
associatifs que vous protégez la
démocratie et la République vous répétez
à l'envie que vous protégez les
institutions en réalité vous les
détournez pour servir les intérêts de
l'argent il est grand temps que viennent
le temps de la Sixième République qui
donne toute sa place à l'intervention
citoyenne et à la majorité sociale du
pays
mais nous avons bien compris madame la
Première ministre le danger pour vous
c'est les insoumis surtout pas l'extrême
droite car vous utilisez leurs mots vous
votez pour elle aux fonctions
importantes vous votez avec elle contre
la hausse du SMIC contre le
rétablissement de la voie de solidarité
sur la fortune ou contre le gel des
loyers vous reprenez ces obsessions pour
la faire monter vous fermez les yeux sur
des ratonnades des défilés fascistes et
des appels au meurtre
l'extrême droite est votre assurance vie
madame la Première ministre
préférée pointer la nupette qui combat à
l'extrême droite mais laissez votre
Ministre de l'Intérieur expliquez à Le
Pen qu'elle est trop molle ou le
président de la République réhabilité
Pétain voici le vrai danger pour notre
République
madame la Première ministre
la République n'est rien sans son peuple
vous aurez beau clamé la défendre en
réalité vous ne tolérez que des citoyens
silencieux et passifs vous n'aimez la
démocratie que lorsqu'elle convient aux
intérêts que vous défendez
dites ce que vous voulez mais ne
prétendez pas être des démocrates
la démocratie n'est pas stable par
essence
c'est un processus qui se construit tous
les jours par lequel les conflits se
résolvent avec votre obstination sur les
retraites vous vous maintenez en état
d'hostilité vis-à-vis du pays sourd à la
détermination des Français à vous faire
entendre l'injustice terrible que vous
faites subir au travailleur et
travailleuses il n'y a pas contrairement
à ce que vous pensez de différence de
nature entre la démocratie et
l'autoritarisme il n'existe entre eux
qu'une différence de degré madame la
Première ministre ne pensez pas un
instant sortir victorieux de cette
guerre d'usure
les républicains vont sûrement
aujourd'hui encore une fois vous sauver
madame la Première ministre mais ce
n'est que partie remise
tôt ou tard vous tomberez car la colère
a dépassé la question des retraites
c'est toute votre politique et votre
monde que le peuple de France rejette
comme les gilets jaunes avant elle
l'immense majorité sociale du pays pose
la question de savoir qui décide
madame la Première ministre allez dire à
l'Élysée que le seul souverain que nous
reconnaissons et le peuple et que nous
n'avons ni roi ni maître
madame la Première ministre
ne pensez pas à sortir victorieux de
cette guerre d'usure
10% des Français ne veulent plus de 7/5
République nous sommes les partisans
d'une sixième république qui permettent
au peuple de se réapproprier sa
souveraineté et de concourir de nouveaux
droits si le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne existait dans ce pays pour
proposer ou abroger des lois alors nous
pourrions sortir par le haut de
l'impasse dans lequel nos amis Emmanuel
Macron nous parlementaires de la nups en
faisant le serment nous n’arrêterons
jamais de lutter contre la retraite à 64
ans et pour le droit à la retraite à 60
ans nous agirons sans relâche par tous
les moyens à notre disposition pour
rassembler la majorité qui mettra fin à
cette réforme injustée injustifiée vous
ne viendrez pas à bout de nous car nul
ne peut interdire durablement un peuple
libre de faire entendre sa volonté
soyez résolus de ne plus servir et vous
voilà libre écrivez Étienne de la Boétie
le peuple y maîtrisable et fier de sa
liberté le peuple qui se lève voici le
vrai visage de la République votez cette
motion de censure collègue comme un
sursaut de dignité de notre Parlement
contre la volonté présidentielle dans
limiter durablement les droits
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
pour le groupe les républicains monsieur
Jean-Louis Thieriot
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente Madame la première
minute mes chers collègues
en démocratie il n'y a pas de minorité
de blocage la Constitution pas davantage
que son article 40 ne sont des options à
la carte c'est pourtant ainsi que
résonne les auteurs de cette motion de
censure ils sont bien loin de leur grand
ancêtre Maurice Thorez qui quelques
années avant de déserter à Moscou avait
eu la sagesse de dire qu'il fallait
savoir terminer une grève il faut savoir
terminer une contestation
ce texte ce texte a été adopté par cette
assemblée par la procédure du 49,3 que
nous regrettons mais qu'importe il a été
adopté ce texte a été validé par le
Conseil constitutionnel ce texte a été
promulgué aujourd'hui cette motion de
censure qui n'a aucune chance d'être
adopté ne vise qu'à prolonger
artificiellement un combat perdu à
maintenir l'agitation dans la rue et à
transformer la démocratie en onclocratie
lorsque votre guide suprême Monsieur
Mélenchon lorsqu'il faut mettre bas la
mauvaise République c'est un bras
d'honneur alors républicain
rien d'étonnant de la part de ceux qui
préfèrent les casseurs de sainte Soline
au gendarmes blessés et les Vandales du
soulèvement de la terre au labeur
patient de nos paysans
tout cela pourquoi pour assister au
mariage de la carpe et les filles et du
lapin
eren alliés objectifs de la politique de
la terre brûlée
à vous entendre nous voyons que les
extraits ont toujours un visage de
frères pour prospérer dans l'outrance
sur les malheurs des plus faibles
cette alliance de fête appel à revenir à
l'esprit de la motion de censure dans
l'esprit du constituant il s'agissait de
proposer une majorité alternative pas
une coaliste pas une coagulation des
oppositions dans le cloaque des arrières
pensées électoralistes pour mettre un
terme assez dérives il faudra me
semble-t-il réfléchir à l'introduction
dans notre loi fondamentale d'une motion
de défiance constructive adaptée à notre
cinquième République sur laquelle je
prépare une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle en attendant vous
l'aurez compris notre groupe ne prêtera
pas la main à la manœuvre politicienne
qui nous occupe car notre famille
politique est celle de l'ordre de la
liberté et du progrès
l'ordre on l'espèce l'ordre
constitutionnel nous avons lu avec soin
votre motion de censure elle ne vise
rien de moins qu'à priver de tout est
fait l'article 40 de notre Constitution
c'est pourtant l'un des fondements de
notre parlementarisme rationalisé trop
instruit par l'exemple de la troisième
et de la Quatrième République où les
logiques clientéliste de ceux qu'on
appelait alors les députés pinardiers
rendaient impossible l'établissement
d'une politique budgétaire à long terme
le constituant dans sa sagesse a décidé
de rendre au gouvernement la plénitude
de son pouvoir budgétaire il n'est pas
possible de conduire la politique de la
nation si les amendements de tel ou tel
accroissent les charges sans les
compenser
l'article 40 mérite d'être respecté le
président de la commission des finances
qui vient de vos rangs ne s'est pas
acquitter de sa charge il a préféré ses
engagements partisans aux devoirs de sa
fonction c'est une sorte de forfaiture
contre laquelle notre groupe ne peut que
s'assurer
la liberté la liberté c'est reconnaître
aux urnes le statut d'arbitre suprême
vous avez perdu la présidentielle vous
avez perdu les législatives Monsieur
Mélenchon n'est pas Premier ministre et
vous perdrez encore car une partie du
peuple de gauche celui qui ne sait pas
couché devant la France insoumise la
France irresponsable relève la tête le
succès de la convention de Bernard
Cazeneuve montre qu'il existe encore une
gauche éminemment républicaine
oui nous voulons la liberté la liberté
de débattre sur le fond d'aller au bout
des textes de porter des amendements
raisonnables pour améliorer le quotidien
du peuple de France nous ne voulons pas
d'un parlement otage de ceux qui
pratiquent l'obstruction de ceux qui
veulent le transformer en ZAD ou en
nager de lunettes nous en avons assez de
vos milliers d'amendements feuilles de
salade ridicule zevins qui ne servent
qu'à paralyser les débats
vous l'avez fait ici à l'Assemblée vous
avez tenté de le faire au Sénat
ne venez pas vous plaindre pompier
Pyroman vous ne faites que nourrir
l'anti parlementarisme des honnêtes gens
qui sont saisis de nausées au spectacle
de notre émission transformé en grand
Guignols
c'est d'améliorer le sort des Français
nous aurions aimé vous voir innovant
originaux révolutionnaire même puisque
vous aimez le terme vous passez votre
temps à dénoncer les super profiques
mais alors soyez cohérents tirez-en les
conséquences proposées d'introduire une
dose de capitalisation dans les
retraites dont chacun sait qu'elle
apporte un meilleur taux de remplacement
et donc une meilleure retraite
un socle par répartition auquel nous
sommes tous attachés et un par
capitalisation pas une capitalisation
pour les plus riches ou seulement les
fonctionnaires avec le Préfon mais pour
tous les salariés pas une capitalisation
à l’américaine ou des fonds anonymes
peuvent jouer avec les parts mieux des
salariés une capitale à la française
obligatoire contrôler par l'État qui
ferait de chaque Français le
bénéficiaire des super profits ce serait
cela une participation intelligente au
sens où l'entendait le général de Gaulle
dans le discours de Bayeux en
feuilletant mes notes je suis tombé sur
un texte intéressant
la capitalisation en soi est
parfaitement acceptable et peut même
bien marier par le prolétariat organisé
éclaire voyant servir très
substantiellement la classe ouvrière
avec la répartition c'est sur les
ressources de l'État que tout repose et
les retraites peuvent être exposées à
toutes les vicissitudes le péril est
moindre l'équilibre est bien plus assuré
s'il y a à l'est de capitaux si la
caisse des retraites possédant des
valeurs à la fois solides et variées
repose non pas sur la base étroite d'un
budget mais surtout de la fortune
publique
ces mots ne sont pas de Milton Friedman
pas de l'école de Chicago pas de
Margaret Thatcher ils sont de Jean
Jaurès mais lui
lui n'avait pas déserté la cause du
peuple il voulait le bien des mineurs de
Carmaux ces camarades de lutte ils ne
cherchait pas à faire de la misère le
terreau de ses succès électoraux
partie de l'ordre
nous entendons tourner la page et
traiter des urgences qui préoccupent les
Français l'immigration pour laquelle
nous avons déposé une proposition de loi
qui garantirait que notre pays c'est ça
d'accueillir ceux qu'il n'aurait pas
choisi
l'inflation qui ronge les salaires la
politique énergétique qui met en péril
nos avantages compétitifs la
réindustrialisation du pays la
transition écologique qui doit devenir
une source de croissance vertueuse et
non punitive pour les plus faibles la
rationalisation de notre administration
enfin qui a fait l'objet d'une
excellente mission de nos collègues
Véronique louvagi et robareda bref
avançons pour le bien du pays notre
famille politique n'apportera pas savoir
à se barreau du déshonneur
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur le Président
bourlange pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mes chers collègues
voilà un bien étrange rendez-vous
républicain
que celui auquel nous convie nos
collègues de la nupesse qui ont déposé
la motion
nous invitons à donner congé au
gouvernement dirigé par Madame Elisabeth
borne
de mémoire de débat de censure
on a semble-t-il jamais vu
motion
aussi chétive
aussi pauvre
et aussi étrangère à l'objet normal d'un
débat de cet ordre que le texte proposé
pour présenter et justifier
l'initiative majeure dont on argument de
ce soir
l'examen d'une motion de censure est à
juste titre considéré comme un moment
très fort de la vie publique un moment
qui voit la représentation nationale
s'interrogeait sur la pertinence sur la
légitimité de l'action du gouvernement
et proposer le cas échéant au chef de
l'État et derrière le chef de l'État au
pays de changer d'équipe de méthode et
de projets c'est un moment dur de notre
vie publique et qui doit en toute état
de cause permettre aux dirigeants de la
nation de faire dans le sérieux et la
clarté leur examen de conscience or que
nous proposons aujourd'hui
à l'appui de ce énième remake de la
condamnation du gouvernement un texte de
quelques lignes qui ne dit rien de la
politique gouvernementale et se contente
de dénoncer les prétendus irrégularités
de procédure qui aurait d'écarter jeudi
dernier l'initiative législative du
groupe iode visant à abroger le report
de l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
le texte rappelle en hors-d'oeuvre
l'utilisation par le gouvernement mais
dans des conditions vont en parfaitement
régulières et jugés comme tel par le
Conseil constitutionnel de divers
articles de la Constitution qui n'ont
pas l'heure de plaire aux oppositions
mais ce que ce texte met vraiment en
cause ce sont les points de procédure
qui ont conduit à l'échec jeudi dernier
de l'initiative du gros pilote le
problème c'est que sur les points
litigieux ce n'est pas le gouvernement
mais le Parlement est plus précisément
l'Assemblée nationale
son bureau c'est commissions le
président de la commission des finances
et bien entendu
la présidente de notre assemblée qui est
en cause et qui devrait être blâmé si
tenter qu'il y ait matière à blâme
l'opposition cherchait un coupable elle
a trouvé le gouvernement on se demande
bien pourquoi d'ailleurs et en fait son
bouc émissaire même s'il est
parfaitement étranger à notre querelle
de l'article 40
[Applaudissements]
la censure n'est pourtant pas un fusil
attiré dans les coins vous avez le
perchoir dans la lunette et vous tirez
sur le banc drôle de chasseur en vérité
avec vous la galinette cendrée ne peut
recevoir qu'une balle perdue
épargnons donc au gouvernement un
injuste procès et laisse son vivre comme
disait le grand du pellet le ce
gouvernement le reste de son âge
concentrons-nous en revanche sur nos
propres responsabilités votre noteule
estonne par son analyse des droits à
l'amendement d'un côté vous contestez la
mise à l'écart pourtant à valise elle
aussi par le Conseil constitutionnel des
avalanches de sous amendement tardif
déposés aux seuls d'obstruction de
l'autre grand écart Vous contestez le
droit constitutionnel offert aux
commissions parlementaires d'amender
projet proposition de loi avant leur
examen en séance publique comme si
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour d'une
proposition de loi dans le cadre d'une
niche devait avoir pour effet de priver
de leurs droits d'amendement les membres
de la commission compétence
le droit environnement en commission
commencer en ce public et la pierre
angulaire des droits du Parlement
la grande querelle est toutefois
ailleurs elle porte son nom
responsabilités de parlementaires
relatives à l'application et au respect
de l'article 40 de la Constitution les
députés du modèle soutiennent avec force
que celles et ceux qui ont contribué à
la décision de rejeter pour
inconstitutionnalité le texte litigieux
avait non seulement le droit mais le
devoir d'ennuiser comme ils l'ont fait
et cela pour deux raisons la première
c'est que les Parlement monsieur Thiriot
vient de le rappeler ont été inventés et
ce sont développés en Angleterre aux
États-Unis en France et en Allemagne
notamment pour lutter contre la
prodigalité des princes et ont protéger
les contribuables le régime
parlementaire est né chez nous de la
nécessité de mettre un terme au désordre
financier de l'ancienne monarchie il y
est dans un premier temps formal parvenu
et c'est pourquoi de gamb pas Tardieu
demandait ce France à felizia de Paul
Reynaud à Michel Debré les plus grands
républicains ont affirmé avec constance
et sous trois républiques la nécessité
de soustraire l'augmentation des charges
et la réduction des recettes à la seule
initiative parlementaire les enjeux
budgétaires et financiers pèsent
aujourd'hui d'un point trop lourd pour
qu'il soit raisonnable de quitter ici
cette voie de la sagesse républicaine la
seconde raison c'est que nos
institutions nous imposent de lourdes
mais légitime responsabilité en la
matière des responsabilités qui sont à
la fois politique juridique et morale la
Constitution le Conseil constitutionnel
qui la protège et tout simplement le
respect que nous nous devons à nous-même
tire dans la même direction et font du
Parlement lui-même le gardien de sa
propre sagesse et le garant premier chef
du respect de l'article 40 on défendra
jamais l'institution parlementaire en la
laissant bafouer la Constitution et
provoquée par réaction ce qui serait une
illusione mise au pas du Conseil
constitutionnel si nous nous laissons
nous nous laissions aller à cette folle
tentation nous ne gagnerions aucun
pouvoir et nous perdrions notre autorité
morale nos procédures nous permettent
d'exercer ce contrôle notre mission nous
y oblige
et c'est bien un site nous en usons nous
avons certes décidé le compte d'exercer
le contrôle le constitutionnalité en
aval et non pas en amont du dépôt et de
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour des
propositions de loi mais cela ne va en
aucune façon
reconnaissant de ce qui serait un
extravagant privilège
l’inconstitutionnalité auto reconnue au
sol parlementaires nos règles ont prévu
en préalable à l'examen et au vote de la
loi de donner au parlementaire les
moyens et au président de la commission
des finances est plus encore à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale le
devoir oui le devoir d'écarter de la
délibération publique des propositions
de loi qui seraient manifestement
contraire à l'article 40 ce qui était
sans contestation possible le cas de la
PPL du groupe yacht
la vérité c'est que dans cette affaire
chacun a joué le rôle qui devait être le
sien chacun a fait son devoir à
l'exception hélas du président de la
commission des finances qui s'est
inventé une légitimité imaginaire de
protecteur d'une opposition non menacée
en vue de soustraire de se soustraire à
ses obligations
institutionnelles si vous tenez mes
chers collègues à sanctionner quelqu'un
dans cette affaire pour non respect de
la Constitution vous tenez votre homme
la vraie galinette cendrée c'est le
président de la commission des finances
un vote de censure mes chers collègues
c'est toutefois où se devrait être tout
autre chose qu'à vote de sanctions
portant sur les articles de procédure le
vote
nous considérons
nous nous considérons que nous voyons
que vos affinités électives entre le RN
et la France insoumise sont fortes sont
fortes je les rappelle
[Musique]
je les rappelle qu'il s'agisse qu'il
vous pouvez vous pouvez s'il vous plaît
je demande le décompte madame qu'il
s'agisse de l'Europe de l'Ukraine de
Poutine de l'OTAN des retraites du SMIC
de la dépense publique de l'allergie à
la démocratie représentative que
d'affiner les tiges entre les bombes
bataillons de LFI et du RN qui se soif
feront l'essentiel de votre chiffre n'en
déplaise à Madame rabot
quant à nous nous voterons ce que nous
pensons au modem c'est qu'il faut que ce
qui se joue aujourd'hui dans le pays et
en Europe ce sont les orientations qui
pour les orientations oui nous ne
voterons pas la censure la différence du
RN et du fi parce que nous croyons
caractérise remplaçable de la démocratie
représentative à la différence de la
France insoumise et du rassemblement
national nous ne voterons pas la censure
parce que nous croyons que seul une robe
forte et unie nous permettra de
préserver nos intérêts nos valeurs face
à un monde débridé nous ne voterons pas
la censure parce que nous considérons
que cet assemblée a mieux à faire
qu'attirer sur le pianiste
[Musique]
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
et pour terminer cette discussion
Monsieur Nicolas Dupont-Aignan pour 5
minutes
madame la présidente Madame la Premier
ministre chers collègues après la
mascara démocratique de jeudi dernier vu
l'état du pays et compte tenu du monde
parallèle dans lequel vit ce
gouvernement cette motion de censure
s'imposait plus que jamais
je pourrais évoquer votre gestion
catastrophique de nos finances publiques
avec notamment la poursuite et j'insiste
d'emprunt d'État taux variables indexés
sur l'inflation véritable cadeau banque
et au marché financier qui nous ont
coûté en 2022 15 milliards d'euros soit
près de 2 fois la réforme des retraites
que vous avez imposées contre les plus
modestes je pourrais aussi aborder le
recul du pouvoir d'achat des Français
jamais vu lié au retard des salaires sur
l'inflation comme à votre compromission
avec des féodalités privées qui
accumulent des supers profits sur le dos
notamment des automobilistes je pourrais
évoquer la faillite de votre politique
migratoire et de sécurité je pourrais
enfin m'indigner de votre refus de
sortir du marché européen de
l'électricité qui ruine nos PME et
explique l'augmentation des défaillances
d'entreprises considérables que vous
cachez par des effets d'annonces
d'emploi dans 5 ans
mais dans les cinq minutes qui me sont
impartis je préfère me concentrer sur le
déni permanent de votre démocratie de
notre démocratie que nous vivons sous
votre gouvernement oui mes chers
collègues la semaine dernière tous les
Français je le dis tous les Français ont
été humiliés car les représentants du
peuple que nous sommes ont été empêchés
d'assumer une de leurs missions
institutionnelle fondamentale qui est de
voter la loi la présidente de notre
assemblée le pistolet sur la tombe comme
la rapportait la presse à déserter sa
fonction et à piétiner la séparation des
pouvoirs qu'elle était censée défendre
rien ne justifiait ce détournement de
procédures de l'article 40 si ce n'est
votre volonté affichée de bâillonner la
souveraineté populaire comme vous
n'aviez pas été capable d'obtenir une
majorité pour reculer l'âge de la
retraite à 64 ans vous saviez
pertinemment que cette assemblée pouvait
voter le retour à 62 ans et donc la
proposition de nos collègues yacht
comment accepter mes chers collègues et
là Monsieur bourlange il ne s'agit pas
de la présidence il s'agit du
gouvernement d'entendre dans les médias
un membre du gouvernement n'a madame
cobel osez dire je cite je cite nous
ferons tout pour que ce débat n'est pas
lieu jamais depuis 1958 à tel
comportement n'a été affiché aussi
franchement en vérité madame la Première
ministre n'écoute pas comme d'habitude
depuis près d'un an Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron vous madame la Première
ministre votre gouvernement et votre
minorité parlementaire n'acceptait pas
le verdict des élections législatives en
refusant comme dans toutes démocratie
adulte de prendre acte de la
représentation nationale comme elle est
voulu par les Français six semaines
après l'élection présidentielle en éc
systématiquement tout compromis avec les
diverses oppositions et en manipulant en
fin de compte notre Constitution pour
toujours passer en force vous liquidez
morceaux par morceau notre démocratie
madame la Première ministre j'entends
d'ici le discours que vous allez
prononcer dans quelques instants mais
pas un Français ne peut être dupe de
votre discours mielleux prétendant
rechercher le dialogue et l'apaisement
alors que vos actes sont ceux en
permanence de la provocation et du déni
démocratie vous donner d'ailleurs des
leçons de
démocratie à la terre entière et ici
même vous refusez au représentants du
peuple le droit d'initiative législative
car c'est de cela dont il s'agissait
jeudi dernier et vous allez pleurer
ensuite sur l'abstention qui mine nos
institutions alors que c'est votre
mépris du peuple Ker chaque jour un plus
grand nombre de nos compatriotes
mais l'histoire de France nous a
heureusement appris qu'on ne peut pas
éternellement gouverner contre le peuple
si ici même chers collègues nous
représentants de la nation acception
sans réagir la forfaiture de la semaine
dernière nous perdrions définitivement
l'estime et le respect de nos
concitoyens alors la rue deviendrait le
seul exutoire de la colère populaire et
c'est pourquoi il est fondamental
urgent important de censurer ce
gouvernement méprisant et arrogant qui
en seulement 9 mois a déjà piétiné le
peuple et notre assemblée à de multiples
reprises et se croit toujours
intouchables mes chers collègues nous ne
redresserons la France qu'avec la
confiance des Français voilà pourquoi
nous ne devons pas avoir peur de la
menace de dissolution car c'est au
peuple français de trancher le conflit
légitimité entre un président isolé et
une assemblée de moins en moins
gouvernable
je vous remercie la discussion est close
je vais mettre voir maintenant la motion
de sang sur le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale je
rappelle que seuls les députés
favorables à l'émotion de censure
participe au scrutin avec le vote se
déroule dans les sales voisines de
l'hémicycle le scrutin va être ouvert
pour 30 minutes il sera clos à 18h25 je
vous indique des après l'annonce du
résultat du scrutin nous examinerons la
proposition de loi visant à faciliter le
passage et l'obtention du permis de
conduire elle est en procédure d'examen
simplifiée il y a 13 amendements à
examiner donc nous pourrons l'examiner
avant la suspension de 20h je vous
remercie la séance est suspendue la
séance est reprise voici le résultat du
scrutin majorité requise pour l'adoption
de la motion de censure soit la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 289 pour l'adoption 239 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée la
séance est levée pour une minute le
temps d'un changement de perchoir
[Applaudissements]